hello my name is stacy ward and i am an
r d manager within cell design studio in
militor sigma and today i will be
presenting on our genetically engineered
immuno-oncology cell lines and services
for early drug discovery research and
pre-clinical manufacturing
within the u.s the life science business
of merck kgaa operates as militor sigma
for the talk today i will begin with an
introduction to our cell design studio
as well as some immuno-oncology
challenges that we have identified
within the field
i will then move on to a discussion of
our antigen panels and finish up with a
discussion of our
hla panel
the cell design studio is a custom cell
line engineering service group within
the life science
group of millipore sigma
we use gene editing tools including
crispr cas9 zinc finger nucleuses short
hairpin and sirna and lentivirus
lentiviral overexpression to engineer
custom cell lines for our customers
we use many different cell types
including peripotent stem cells primary
immune cells and transform cell lines
and we can pretty much engineer any type
of modification that you might desire
including single nucleotide
polymorphisms
gene knockouts
large reporter cell lines and such
we use many screening tools including
next generation sequencing digital
droplet pcr and junction pcr for genomic
interrogate interrogation
as well as phenotypic assays including
philosophy microscopy as well as things
like cell migration in a dish
and the cells that we engineer can be
used for any downstream application
including in vivo testing
ips differentiation and high throughput
screening to name a few
but at the end of the day what we do is
we genetically engineer cells that are
modified to our customer specifications
and while doing our cell line
engineering service for our customers we
have started moving into the immuno
oncology space
and what we found within the field is
that it is a very long and arduous
process to get from identifying a
disease that you might be interested in
attempting to treat and getting to the
clinical phase of actually testing your
treatment in people
so we wanted to use our skill set at
engineering cell lines to try to
both improve the cost and shorten the
timeline for our customers
and when we look at this timeline once a
disease has been selected to potentially
target
a target id needs to be identified and
or a pathway
many assays need to be developed in
order to test these
targets or pathways in vitro and most
often or not these include some sort of
high throughput screening assay
and then once the customer has a hit
that they are interested in pursuing
there is also a space for us within the
um
lot release and pre-clinical testing of
whatever
pharmaceutical or
or target that they are interested in
identifying
so where we thought that we could fit in
is within the assay development
phase of this where we can engineer cell
lines that our customers can use
to screen for their targets or for any
sort of lot release essay
and when we think about what these
targets could potentially be
this is a screenshot from a figure from
a paper published in 2019
that shows the target landscape compared
from drugs in the pipeline in 2017 to
2019 so only two years difference
what we can see here is obviously there
is a
wide increase in the number of targets
that are going to be investigated within
just those two years
in addition to that
the size of each of these bubbles is
directly related to how many potential
drugs are targeting each of these
targets
it boxed in red on the right are three
such targets including cd19 egfr and ny
eso one which are three of the targets
that we decided to pursue for some of
our off-the-shelf cell lines
that could potentially be used for early
drug discovery as well as pre-clinical
testing
so while working with our customers to
engineer their cell lines we have
identified some challenges within the
field
these start with the development
pipeline including target identification
from patient samples so once a disease
has been identified as a customer being
interested in potentially targeting
these patient samples prove very
valuable to try to identify either
mutated genes or pathways that could
potentially be a target
however the utilization of transformed
cell lines for clinical pre-discovery
and compound reagent testing are also
equally important since patient samples
do not grow typically grow very well in
culture
so the current limitations within this
pipeline
include things like in vitro testing
that requires negative control cells
that do not express the target of
interest and positive control cells
which do express the target of interest
and what we have found is that currently
used control cells may not be from the
same person organ or even lineage which
can lead to high background and false
positive and negative results
so we have identified that the field
needs non-passage limited easy-to-grow
and scalable cell lines that are
pertinent to clinical endpoints
if these cells are amenable to 96 384
well assays have affordable and easy
culture conditions and are able to
produce robust and reproducible results
and this is where we thought that our
strengths in cell line engineering could
come into play
this is an example of some of the target
cell lines that are typically used in
drug discovery and preclinical testing
this is a paper from 2013 which was
looking at two b-cell lymphoma targets
cd19 and cd22
positive and negative controls were
required for these assays so a cell line
that expresses
cd19 but not cd22 or cd22 and not cd19
and what this group did was they simply
took the available cell lines that are
easy to culture
and they assayed them for how much
protein they expressed on the surface as
shown in this panel on the upper
left-hand side
and what you can see on the bottom part
b
is that these cell lines do express
varying levels of each of these proteins
but when we look at the primary patient
samples on the right hand side of the
slide they also express varying levels
of these proteins
you can easily see that this is a very
complicated set of cells to attempt to
use for any sort of pre-clinical testing
or lot release
since
they express varying different varying
different levels of the protein
so we asked the question of what if
instead of using a mixture of cell types
from different organs or tissues or
lineages you could use a matched panel
of cells that grew with the same media
and similar growth kinetics and
morphology for your pre-clinical studies
and we set to do this
for what we're calling our
tumor-associated antigen panel cell
lines
we have identified parental cancer cell
lines that grow very well in culture and
typically express the tumor-associated
energy of interest endogenously
we perform genetic knockout experiments
using zinc finger nucleases to render
these cells null
for this tumor-associated antigen of
interest thus giving you a negative
control cell line
we then took these knockout cells
and we delivered the tumor-associated
antigen of interest via lentivirus
and we perform single cell cloning and
identified clones that express
differential levels of the proteins
thus giving you one cell line that
expresses low levels of the protein and
another cell line that expresses high
levels of the protein
but all of these came from the parental
cell line they grow the same in culture
use the same media conditions and they
are amenable to high throughput screens
the three cell lines that we chose to
use for our three tumor-associated
antigen panels that we'll be presenting
today
include ragi cells which are a b-cell
lymphoma cell line
that express the cd19 antigen of
interest
a549 cells which are lung cancer cell
lines which express egfr and a375 cells
which express the nyeso1 type
this is the data that we generated on
our rajis19 antigen panel
cd19 is a cell surface molecule that is
expressed on the surface of b-cells and
highly expressed on the surface of
b-cell lymphomas
we generated our knockouts using zfns
and used next generation sequencing to
confirm the genotype of these cells as
well as extensive phenotyping using flow
cytometry
on the right side of this slide you can
see that our knockout cell line does not
express cd18 on the surface
and we were able to find two single cell
clones that expressed either a low level
of cd19 shown in red or a high level of
cd19 shown in blue and i would like to
point out that these low and high
phrases that i am using are in general
relative to the endogenous level of the
protein on the provincial fill line
before we engineer the knockout
for our egfr panel we chose a549 lung
cancer cells
egfr is a receptor tyrosine kinase that
is known to be mutated in many different
types of cancer including lung cancers
we again used zfns to generate knockouts
in a549 cells there are actually three
copies of egfr within the genome so we
were able to knock out all three copies
within our parental knockout cell line
and then when we redelivered the egfr
expression using lentivirus we were
again shown on the right able to find a
low expressor and a high expressor
in addition to delivering wildpipe egfr
into this panel
we also delivered a commonly found
mutant of egfr so egfr v3
is a
naturally occurring variant of egfr
often found in cancers
this
is an in-frame deletion which actually
causes egfr to lose its ligand
dependence and become constitutively
active so it is always signaling when
you have this egfr v3 mutation we took
the same egfr parental knockout cell
line that i showed you on the previous
slide
and this time we delivered the egfr v3
variant via lentivirus
and what was interesting is that we were
unable to find a low or a high
expressing clone all of the clones that
we acted had the same level of egfr on
the surface
and when we think about this
biologically it makes a lot of sense
because this is a receptor tyrosine
kinase that performs intracellular
signaling upon binding with a ligand but
since this variant 3
loses its ligand dependence it's always
on so you can think of it as
egfr typically works as a dimmer switch
so either it's off in the absence of
ligand if you have a little bit of
ligand it might be a dim signaling
pathway but if you have a lot of ligand
it's going to be signaling quite a bit
with the v3 it's more like an on off
either you have the v3 and you have
signaling or you don't express v3 and
you don't see any signaling and that
data is shown on the right hand side of
the slide where we were only able to
find one level of egfr v3 expression
however when we used a pan-egfr antibody
we do see quite high expression of this
protein on the cell surface
the third tumor-associated antigen panel
that i would like to talk about today is
a little bit different
so ny eso 1 is not actually a protein
coding gene it is a peptide so it is
encoded by two genes c tag one and c tag
two which are present on the x
chromosome
the nye so 1 is a derivative of the
protein product of these two genes but
it is a small peptide that has been
found to be presented on the surface of
many different cancer cells
and this includes colon cancer and a375
cells are a commonly used colon cancer
derived cell line
so this was a little more complicated
since um
the nye so peptide is potentially
encoded by two different genes but again
using our zsn system we were able to
cleanly find clones that had a knockout
of all of the c tags one and two genes
shown in the middle panel using our next
generation sequencing pathway
in addition the ny etho is not as i said
it's not a full protein it's more like a
peptide
so instead of using a flow cytometry
phenotyping assay we decided to use a
western blotting assay so that we could
see all of the peptide that was
potentially expressed within the cell
and you can clearly see that our
knockout cell line in the first lane
does not express any ctag gene product
and we in this case we were able to find
both low expressing clones and high
expressing clones
so to summarize i have shown you data on
our anagen panels that include cancer
relevant cell pipes that express varying
levels of the antigen of interest
and we feel that these tools will be
useful for early drug discovery antibody
compound testing or assay development
and due to our experience in custom cell
line engineering if this is something
that is of interest of you to you we can
also develop custom antigen panels in
your cell line of choice so whether you
have a particular cell line that you
work in or a target of interest that we
have not covered in today's talk please
reach out to us and we can
generate a custom cell line for your
uses
so to change gears a little bit um the
next panel that i would like to talk
about is our hla panel so so far i've
presented data on tumor-associated
antigen expressing cells but something
that we need to remember within the
immuno ecology field is that it's not as
simple as a cell line just expressing a
target of interest
so
when we think about the immune system
targeting cancer cell lines or tumor
cells
we need to also think about specifically
the t cells so i really like this
cartoon on the left hand side of this
slide where you have a somatic cell
that's expressing a protein or a peptide
of interest within an mhc class one and
a cytotoxic t cell comes along and says
i'm sorry but i don't recognize the mhc
peptide complex you have there
and it makes him sad because now the t
cell does not recognize him can't kill
him can't do anything and just goes
along his way
so what we need to remember here is that
t cells will only be stimulated to
target tumor cells when the tcr
recognizes an mhc bound peptide
and these hla dependent therapies can
include cytotoxic t lymphocytes as well
as peptide rna or a dna vaccine
and to look at this a little bit more
in detail this is a cartoon that
i'm using from a paper published in 2008
which shows on the bottom an
antigen-presenting cell and on the top
um an mhc
hla b8 restricted t cell
so the t cells will only recognize
peptides as presented by hla b8 on the
left hand side of this slide this is a t
cell that can recognize this peptide in
the hla b8 groove
however in the middle
we have the t cell and we have the
correct peptide but the antigen
presenting cell instead of putting it in
hla b8 it is putting it in hla b44 so
even though it's exactly the same
peptide the t cell does not recognize it
because it doesn't see that mhc type 1.
on the right hand side the antigen
presenting cell is expressing the
correct hla but it is actually
presenting a different peptide so that
also is not recognized by the t cell so
what we can think of with this system is
a very discreet
lock and key mechanism
where the t cell you can think of as
lock in the antigen presenting cell as
the key and everything needs to
completely match up for that t cell to
recognize the antigen presenting cell
and potentially kill it which is what
we're looking for with immunotherapy
so again using our expertise in gene
engineering we thought well this makes
for a very
complicated potential in vitro testing
system
um
when you think about hla class mhc class
ones
you receive hlas a b and c
one copy from each of your parents
though so that's potentially six
different hlas that you're presenting on
the surface
and while that's really great for the
biology of your immune system because it
gives your t cells a lot of diversity
it can make assays with these cells
quite difficult and the data can be a
little bit messy
so using a protocol that was first
published in 2015 we thought okay well
what if we can knock out all of the
endogenous mhc class ones on our cell
lines and only produce one um and that
way you're not limited by the cancer
cell line anymore if the cancer cell if
the cancer cell line of interest that
you're using only expresses hla a1
but the t cell that you're interested in
testing expresses or recognizes hla a2
you can no longer use that cancer cell
line but what if we can take that cell
line that you're used to culturing and
you're very comfortable with and we can
just engineer it to express hla a2 then
you have a system that you can use in
your lab
so
instead of the laborious task of
attempting to knock out six different
genes all of which differ by only a
grouping of single nucleotide
polymorphisms
we decided to knock out a partner
protein known as beta2 microglobulin
this is shown in the diagram on the
lower left hand side
beta 2m is an important part of mhc
class 1 because it is what chaperones
the mhc complex mhc class 1 complex to
the cell surface so without beta 2m even
though you still produce hla protein it
cannot get to the surface and when we
think about t cells interacting with
tumor cells if it's not on the surface
the t cell can't see it
so we use the fm to knock out the beta
2m gene
and we carefully confirmed that this
were true knockouts so we did this using
sequencing as well as phenotyping assays
just to make sure that we weren't having
breakthrough or erroneous expression of
the hlas on the surface and we have not
seen that in any of the cells that
we've tested
so once we have this beta 2m null cell
line we again use lentivirus to deliver
single hlas into the cell
and we confirmed the expression via
phenotyping
so we chose three different cell lines
we used a549 cells again our lung cancer
cell line the jerkit cell line which is
a t lymphocyte cell line and raji cells
which are a b lymphocyte cell line
and on the right hand side of the slide
we picked some of the most commonly
found
human mhc class 1 shown on the right we
focused on hla a and hla b for this
first panel
and we expressed each of these hla
singularly within the cells
in this slide is a representation of
some of the data that we generated using
these panels so for this
example i am showing data from the a549
hla panel
on the upper right hand corner
wild type a549 cells are shown here in
blue expressing beta 2m on the surface
and our knockout cell lines are shown in
red so when we knock out beta 2m you no
longer get beta2m on the surface we have
also stained these cells with pan
mhc class 1 antibodies and similar to
the beta 2m expression we also do not
see any expression of hlas on the
surface in our knockout cell line
once we delivered each of the single
shown here into this knockout parental
phone line
you can see very clearly that we get
high expression of beta 2m on the
surface and again when we stain these
cells with a pan mhc class 1 antibody
we see similar results so we are getting
high expression of not only the beta 2m
but also the hla on the surface and we
have also done internal testing
looking for
whether any of the endogenous hlas are
pulled to the surface once we over
express these hlas
however with our lentiviral construction
we have fused beta-2m to each of these
hla types so we only see the fusion
protein product on the surface we don't
see any of the endogenous hlas but we
have carefully looked for each of these
panels
so to summarize the second part of the
talk we have developed cancer relevant
cell types that express individual mhc
class 1 alleles and we have done this in
8549 cells joicit cells and rawgi cells
and i only showed data for the a549s but
the data for the jirkets and the rajes
look very similar
these cell-based assays can be used to
evaluate tcr therapies as well as
peptide and oncolytic vaccine
development um and just to point out if
you have other hlas that you are
interested in expression expressing or
another cell line um other than the
three that i've talked about today we
can of course do this on a custom basis
so i hope that i've convinced you that
the utilization of one cell line that
expresses varying levels of a
tumor-associated antigen will aid in
your pre-clinical discovery and
validation
and that monoxilic hla class 1
expressing cells will be a useful tool
for any immuno oncologist interested in
peptide presentation and t-cell killing
assays
the data that i've shown today is all
encompassed within our off-the-shelf
tumor-associated antigen and hla cell
lines
you can find the website here
in addition as i mentioned we do provide
customs online engineering as well so
please visit our cell design studio
webpage and
we would be happy to provide you with
any additional information you may want
so just to finish up
using our expertise in tailoring
cellular models to customer needs we can
perform any sort of modification that
you might envision including knockouts
targeted integration we can deliver
clones or pools
we are very experienced in induced
pluripotent stem cells and primary stem
cell culture
and any of these cell lines can be used
for any number of drug discovery
applications or other applications even
if you're not within the drug discovery
field and we really do look at ourselves
as research partners
we are not a cro we are a partner with
you so you will have access to our phd
level scientists and over a decade of
experience in engineering cells and
it's rare that we find a cell type that
we have not engineered in the past so i
encourage you to please reach out to us
with any questions you may have
so with that i would like to thank you
for your attention and i hope that
you have a wonderful day thanks